mit netten und harmlosen daten
abgefangen
nein gemeinen und unter dem wagen nein
auch nicht nein mit gemeinden und
harmlosen fragen
immerhin waren die roten war richtig
genau ein vorziehen und ich garantiere
die heute 19
die avu erlebnisse das heißt du wirst
alles hier irgendwie die roten sind die
gemeinden sind wirklich gemein und was
macht ihr mit hoher und dann beantwortet
die frage was ist frauenfragen neues
album hauptrolle in einem zdf mehrteiler
erfolgreiche youtuber show selbst
vollkommen ab tatsächlich auf dem boden
ich meine persönlichkeit meine aura chip
nicht ob ich bleibe so wie ich bin und
werde nie vergessen wo ich herkomme oder
woher ich herkomme sag mir wo ich
herkomm wo es herkommt wo komme ich her
wo wirklich ein eltern stärken wo auch
so meine eltern und ich komme aus
schöneberg
sie sind jetzt sogar ganze leben in der
türkei wärmer na ja die haben wir lange
zeit verbreitet also ist alles schön und
gut das kann noch viel mehr passiert
natürlich aber ich werde trotzdem nicht
vergessen jetzt jetzt mehr
die nächste frage noch eine rote wurde
sinnvolle abwechslung zu machen neues
album hauptrolle in einem zdf mehrteiler
erfolgreiche youtuber show was das
geheimnis seines erfolges viel fleiß am
ball bleiben wenn man sich selber
glauben und einfach scheiße durchziehen
wie ich war oft durch die scheiße ist
das was damit zu tun hat
es ist so man geht durch die scheiße und
dann kommt so eine gelegenheit eine
chance die chance einfach vernünftig und
sinnvoll ausnutzen
sein bestes geben und ich denke es kommt
noch eine chance ist es sowas wie meine
chance gewesen einer harten zeit und ich
habe die chance einfach ausgedruckt und
an erster stelle an mich genau gibt es
leute die keine chance programm gibt es
auch ich war einer von denen aber dann
habe ich doch eine chance vielleicht
schicksal
das ist vielleicht noch die eine chance
hatte aber manche hatten die chance
haben nichts draus gemacht und kriegen
jetzt keine andere weitere chance weißt
du es ist zu spät wie ich vorhin schon
gesagt habe die letzte reue hilft auch
nicht viel
man muss vorher überlegen das ist wohl
wahr
rot-rot habe meine ergänzen sich mach
dich mal so gut gefällt mir so was haben
wir da das spielt eine hauptrolle in dem
zdf mehrteiler verbrechen haben die beim
casting nicht richtig hingeguckt
das wort sein
also ich weiß nicht ob die geguckt oder
nicht richtig glauben
ich hatte kein casting nicht ich brauche
jetzt der richtige ja ich wurde direkt
angefragt
wahrscheinlich schon die beim blues
brothers film nicht richtig hingeguckt
wieso nicht wieder auf mich willkommen
sind ein paar stück berlin nicht okay
aber ich glaube nicht dass sie damit
einen fehler gemacht haben ok jetzt
kommen wir das kann jetzt kommen erst
rappen dann schauspielern und jetzt noch
eine eigene youtube show woher nimmst du
diese ganze energie
die energie kommt automatisch wenn man
etwas vorhat
also man muss halt natürlich auch drauf
bock haben und der wille ist da für so
etwas wie eine show schauspielern also
das ist so gelegenheit ist da und ich
der wille ist auch dabei wenn ihr
gelinge das warum nicht es genau wie die
die chance die man kriegt und die
energie kommt dann von alleine weil man
die ganze zeit nichts zu tun hatte jetzt
passiert endlich was okay aber das ist
ganz klar rot nicht so leicht kommt
wieder diese erst wird dann
schauspielern und jetzt noch eine
youtube show ist das nicht ein bisschen
zu viel terminkalender ist auf jeden
fall immer voll ist irgendwo viel aber
umso besser das ist halt ein positiver
stress weil es passiert was
es ist schön wenn man nicht die ganze zu
hause rumsitzen muss und auf etwas
warten muss es ist noch schöner wenn der
terminkalender voll ist und jeden tag
gibt es zu tun
also es ist nicht so viel das ist genau
richtig
was jetzt alles kommt wäre auch noch gut
vielleicht weil es um irgendwann zu viel
aber ich bin noch hungrig deswegen ist
zu viel habe gut und noch eine grüne zum
abschluss vielen dank an dieser stelle
schon mal reli ich habe bereitwillige
beantwortung gefahren für diese netten
fragen brühl spielt seine hauptrolle in
dem zdf mehrteiler verbrechen woher
kommen deine vielfältigen talente ja die
kommen aus mir selber raus also ich habe
selbst auch nicht gedacht dass ich so
viele talente habe und es ist halt auch
gerade das schöne so wenn man was in
sich noch entdeckungen von dem man nicht
wusste bei uns eine typische sagt man
komischerweise habe ich glaube ich auf
alle zehn fingern jeden fingern wie ein
talent also ich bin besetzt mit talenten
ich glaube da kommt noch mehr jetzt bin
ich ja gerade dabei auch instrumente
spielen ich lerne gerade und stopp kommt
noch ein bisschen mehr zunächst schon
nächstes jahr beim nächsten album was
wenn jetzt moment lässt eigentlich das
hat beantwortet dem kunst ist irgend so
ein saiteninstrument
und ich wollte das schon immer
ich wollte schon immer so spielen aber
ich bin ich dazu gekommen und jetzt hab
ich halt so lust und bock drauf und ich
will so viel verlernt und mein fans
vielleicht zur tour zur nächsten tour
eine andere show abliefern und
entertainment absolut bruder